responsible for a lot of excesses Mr
security I'm sorry I do have to just
interrupt you there we have to cross
over to Sochi very quickly uh to listen
to the press conference between the
President Putin of Russia and president
erdogan of Turkey let's just listen in
quickly so that we make our situation
with the energy sector in the region
more stable and I think there will be a
positive dynamic as well I already
mentioned agricultural area
we need to expand the number of goods
that you supply to Russian market and we
are talking about a very good volume
and also with regards to metal industry
we have very good positive perspectives
I already mentioned energy we are very
confident in developing this direction
we agreed with the main suppliers and
consumers on both sides and I hope that
this will continue this trend will
continue in the nearest Future
the building of nuclear power station
with turkey is going on Turkey now he is
the member of the international Club of
nuclear countries after the supply of
the first batch of Russian nuclear Fuel
and next year if everything goes as
planned we will launch the first block
and their interesting variants how we
can develop our collaboration
there is a qualified Kim 25
000 people working on this
we have topics to discuss especially how
to ensure
safety in the region and of course we
will pay attention to the Chris question
with regards to the Ukrainian crisis I
know that we want to discuss grain deal
and there will be negotiations to this
effect of course
have done a lot for the situation in
Syria and I know how sensitive topic
this is for Turkish Republic
and the main topic that was in the
in this format we need to
enforce this the area and also in the
other regions but I mean
I mean Olivia track as well there are
many uh bilateral topics and the
international
themes that we will be discussing today
thank you very much that you have come
to visit us and we will have a very good
meeting
true
the Vladimir Putin of Russia welcoming
his Turkish counterpart Richard erdogan
who's also now speaking really President
Putin talking about the fact of uh his
nuclear ambition certainly in selling a
domestic nuclear fuel but also saying
that wanted to talk about the grain deal
which he knew was top of the agenda and
that they hope there could be some sort
of resolution and also uh the Syrian
conflict and whether some resolution
could actually be achieved here of
course president erdogan and turkey are
a member of NATO perhaps the only
country that can really speak to Russia
uh whole wearing those two hats at the
moment both with an ear to the concerns
of the Western Alliance and also
listening to the concerns of what is
actually a close Ally in terms of Russia
over the years it had very close
dealings they are neighbors across the
Black Sea but also have very close
working relationships through their
Regional neighbors whether it be
Azerbaijan or Armenia or Georgia Romania
and therefore very important that they
are actually able to talk I think we can
now listen to what president erdogan has
to say through a translator the local
currency
in between
us and
developments in acquire Nuclear Power
Plant
are ongoing very well as you expressed
it is an important thing that we have
many employed there
the steps taken are very pleasing
as talked about before
it is also possible for us to take
another step
forward as regards
sin up
plant
the fact that there will be a hub
and Trace will be in and out of itself
another richness and a source of
activity another important thing in
between turkey and Russia is related
with tourism and in tourism
uh
Russia comes first
of it in turkey and together with these
all
another important
step is to do with our visit
today and everyone is following the
grain corridor
issue and everyone is expecting to see
what will come out as regards the grand
corridor
today and I believe that following the
meetings we shall have today we will
give a message to the world
especially for
underdeveloped African countries the
step we shall take will be very
important another important thing for us
is to do with defense industry
possible steps we have already taken and
will take
in the field of energy
especially in terms of natural gas
we
with Russia
have been engaged and a very important
relationship
and I believe that this will continue
that President Edward of course talking
about what he hopes that can come out of
this meeting that he's now holding with
uh President Putin of Russia in the
coastal city of Sochi talking about
obviously uh their Mutual understanding
of construction projects mainly nuclear
plants and supply of nuclear civilian
fuel uh tourism obviously up on the
agenda of him but he said that you know
the world wants an answer and they need
to send the world a message regarding
the Ukraine Corridor which of course he
means about the grain deal that
everybody is waiting uh to hear and of
course uh that the fact that Russia has
pulled out of that deal perhaps he's
hoping that he can try and convince uh
the Russian president to get back into
that deal because obviously it's uh
developing the African countries that
also need that help and that they want
to take on the uh subjects of Defense
which both countries are very
um highly strung about at the moment
with what's going on respectively and
also their their joint products projects
in terms of natural gas an important uh
relationship as he describes it let's
listen to what President Putin has to
say
we can't quite hear what President Putin
is saying through our translator at the
moment but I think it's General
pleasantries now uh and a little bit of
understanding of what the details the
agenda of this meeting are going to be
and it seems that that press conference
has finished uh via Russian television
you are watching Al Jazeera